[Music]
as quickly about myself my name is
Victor I work at Compline coal confluent
how many of you heard about counselin
before how many if you heard about Kafka
okay fantastic
awesome crowd I worked there as
developer of the kid as a developer at
the kid I traveled the world talk to
developers sometimes I'm building
applications that demos that actually
work
hopefully today sometimes I just want to
listen how the people struggle with
their applications sometimes just get an
offer I don't know just a hug maybe if I
can help technically I can at least help
to observe their pain yeah so this is
the part of my job to talk to people
that's why I'm enjoying doing this kind
of conferences and really cool stuff
that we're doing is an actual office
hours where we can talk about things
that care that you care not I'm
presenting stuff all right
some of the things that I will be
talking today maybe look odd weird and
stuff but like Marty McFly said you
might be not in the Centers right now
but they're kids gonna love it so we're
going to be talking about about key
sequel which is a streaming sequel for
Apache Kafka it is a development of the
key sequel sponsored by confluence
development happens in open so you can
go in the github you'll find the source
code there you can see the what what is
going on there but before you do that
this my goal is you to involve in this
kind of process before you do that I
want to do introduction and I will talk
about some of the things that we do with
key sequel or you can do with key sequel
I'll show what I can do with K sequel so
this why we need to use them we need to
use a Twitter and your tweets
if you don't know hashtags it's
conveniently placed on every slide also
follow me there follow confluent if
you're interested in any type of
streaming data story all right quick 101
on stream processing
stream processing is the processing of
stream of events so what is an event
event it's a I like this description
it's a shared narrative to describe
business but essentially it's just as
something
that happened and usually this is
something that happened and you cannot
change this and it happened somewhere in
the past you captured this and this
something has happened in certain order
so what is something it's kind of it can
be some sort of event that happens on
your customer support portal like
someone filed a ticket so it will create
event that ticket created or someone
that rated you were a product and said
hey I really love this I don't know like
shoes whatever and this is creates event
like a rate create it or something like
that the sale it happened
someone is paid for something it will
create another event that sale happened
that we can derive some other events for
example you will trigger some workflow
that will be starting fulfilling your
order or some other workflow that will
be starting preparing the shipping labor
so far and so on some other stuff very
popular use case for streaming data is
data that reads from the sensors and the
sensors data IOT data is also consists
of certain events temperature went up
temperature went down like pressure went
up and down some other things that might
happen within this particular domain so
certain readings is also those event
this is also type of event that might
happen who can tell me what is this okay
I'll give you a pointer apart from the
arnold schwarzenegger being his best in
his young what he is caring
look-look-look ship-lock expectation
luxury i like this so essentially the
way how the people start applying that
this all thing streaming they start
streaming the log files from their web
servers oh right with you so all the
stuff that comes through the log HTTP
eve or some other systems also come is a
set of events usually this events are
ordered by time and you know exactly
when something is happened so
interesting point here there is an
analogic between actual log application
log and the data structure that we use
to store this data it's also called law
and it probably is the I don't know
maybe it's the second important data
structure that any date engine needs to
know in my opinion another one it would
be a hashmap because it's basically if
you know how to how to implement hash
map you know how to implement pretty
much any database and probably be tree
and apart from the being this like a
very common interview question when you
go in into states and the officer as the
customs will ask you oh what's your
occupation your programmer okay what's
the be tree can you walk through be tree
for me if not if you lion you might be
in trouble so this why it's very
important to know data structure
especially if you software engineer or
data engineer so log is a data structure
that all the records are actually
ordered by time somehow ordered by time
there's some sequence you cannot change
those events so you can't change those
records and the way how you can deal
with this data you always reading data
and writing data continuously so you're
reading from the beginning of the file
you're writing to the end of the file or
to the end of the log same thing as you
do with application law so now you know
what Apache cough case
so essentially pancha Kafka is
implementation of this distributed log
data structure that provides ability to
capture this events and store those
events and replay those events for
processing why it is important if you
ever look to implementation of the
common data databases databases will
have all this conception of transaction
lock when they capture all events that
happen if your data and after date that
the base management system will
materialize that the table is of use and
some things like that so database is
fundamentally we use this lock so they
if we will tap into this transaction log
we can actually capture this special
type of event that we call change data
capture events in this case we can
implement replication of four databases
for example the way how them the tools
that does the duplication of data bases
is actually just
listening transactional databases all
right so to illustrate how this looked
like again all events go into the end of
the file and we're reading this from
beginning of the file so over the time
we're populating the stream of events we
have a two types of events read events
and yellow ends now who wants to start
processing in those two wins and what
does it mean processing so for example
we want to apply some sort of function
like we want to apply the predicate here
and can say hey I want I'm interested
only in red events here so what I can do
so I will be a reading the stream of
events message by message and after that
we'll be checking if there is a property
in this event saying that hey I'm red or
I'm yellow if it's red I will pass this
to another stream if it's yellow I will
just skip it the way how to describe
this you can use any language the I will
have a Java background and I do have a
like a broad lot of like Java code and
in order to write this I will use
probably Kafka consumer will read the
message and after that will deserialize
the message and figure out what's the
Java object is there and if they has a
property of read and after that I will
do some if statement
some people prefer different languages
while we're developing some of the
stream processing tools at confluent we
figure out that a lot of people who want
to use stream processing tools they're
not programmers they want to do
something with this data but they don't
really need to know what's the I don't
know Scala for example or or Cortland or
whatnot or or a Python APRI probably
data engineers you probably know what's
Python is right okay cool so at least
here so we decide to to implement
something that people kind of sort of
know what is this so we decide to go
with the sequel approach so in this case
majority of the people understand how it
works so essentially this is how we want
people to program with their stream
processing applications using this
sequel like approach so in this case
this is where you apply your predicate
you check in if there's a property of
this particular event has this property
color and after that
we will read everything from initial
stream and we're creating another stream
that we called vigils rep so this is
this concept that that we use we're
going to be operating around this kind
of concepts we have a streams of events
that coming into the system and we
derive another or another few of the
streams that will be that will be used
there now so in order to this to work
Kafka will be source system key sequel
is designed to work with Kafka and
reading data from Kafka and writing data
to Kafka in order to integrate with
other systems we're using this part of a
penci Kafka cold cough connect about
integrations that we'll talk a little
bit in a in a couple more slides so
essentially if you want to bring your
database you need to bring this database
to Kafka somehow which is graphic
Connect will help you to do it apart
from the being the source for data and
in the destination for data from
kissy-kissy will also use this Kafka as
intermediate storage so Kafka and Kasich
well they only use each other so you
don't need to bring another like
database system in order to key sequel
to work for example to store
intermediate state for some stateful
stream processing operations
and the key sequel allows you to
actually develop full-blown applications
using K sequel language which is
extension of this traditional a sequel
image alright so how are we going to be
interacting with the key sequel so we do
have a bunch of us at confluent with
develop tools for stream processing for
interacting with a geographical have
this awesome tool called confident
control center it's a free for
development you can grab this it's free
you can run this on your laptop and
start writing this stuff we do have same
UI in in our console and cloud offering
but like we real date engineers we work
with console right or we're using uise
who is in UI it's a no shame place I'm
just asking I'll just try to understand
I love you guys I love good you guys but
the console works was awesome I will be
using this the confluent confluence
sorry IKEA will see like in sequel
Scylla is just
just a tool that allows me typing two
commands into this black screen but
essentially what does what does it use
under colors is actually used as REST
API so key sequel represents the way how
you can interact with key sequin
low-level it just can use this REST API
that's it you can write your javascript
application that will continue write
data and read data to key sequel and get
the result in the streaming fashion and
I believe it's just like continues
continues query which is like a log
polling type of type of thing so and key
signal supports nancial a JSON out of
the box so you can you know easily write
some of the tools for JavaScript so
three things UI CLI and rest interface
so a couple use cases I will before I
bring to demo how you can use case equal
to do stuff so the simplest possible
thing that is a part of the whole subset
of dream processing tool that we call
stateless string processing is a
filtering right you have a stream of
events you need to create another stream
of event that doesn't have certain
fields or maybe does have certain field
the way I'll how I say about things I
start with negative so doesn't have
meaning that I have a certain
nationality so and we Russians always
think about the negative things first
so doesn't have certain things or does
have certain things all right so the way
how we can do this you can do this with
particular queries so we have a stream
of the orders that comes from New York
that comes from everywhere and we want
to create only orders that have New York
State as a address so couple interesting
things that you can see here so first of
all we have this interesting construct
that allows us also traverse into some
sort of data structure we have an object
a dress that has a field Street we also
can use this kind of firm and syntax to
traverse and find this so we can operate
with the tree-like structures that we
have in json so it's very very
convenient and this is what result look
like so
is what our object is how this object
looked like in the at the very beginning
so it's like she's like this so we do
have a would you have this object about
orders and we have an address as another
the nested object so using the syntax we
can also traverse inside but what what
also what we can do we actually can do
some sort of like modification on the on
the fly so we have some information
about when this message was inserted
that will generate this system a level a
property called roll time that will
register when the time was like there is
a time when this message was inserted
into into Kafka and we can use this
function called x times time to shrink
that allows you to perform some sort of
formatting so on the as a result some of
the some of these messages we on the on
the result stream we actually have some
sort of like a modification and changing
some of the it on the fly so another
very interesting use case when you need
to flatten the same same structure so we
have this structure that has embedded
objects same the order data and this
order data has or address data and now
we can only extract some of the
information about this orders and we
will have a flattened structure if our
consumer did someone who interesting in
this result in the flattened format will
expect this so next thing is that we can
modify the way how the data is
sterilized or stored inside inside the
coffee and how the key cycle trading
this so by default it has a three format
supported as a delimited Jason and Avro
how many heard about Avro okay nice how
many heard about comma separated text
how many you came from the financial
industry and the know this is the most
loved enterprise format now I see I'm
I'm trying to be positive here not most
hated but most loved yeah so we do have
to support this
of the box so if you have a data that
comes in JSON it can be transferred into
text delimited format like this or you
can do wise versa so this kind of like a
changes from the JSON to avril also can
be done very quickly and just changing
the value format so in this case we're
just having creating new stream and we
specifying this with clause that allows
us to manipulate data format allows us
to manipulate the Kafka topic structure
we can define number of partitions we
can define now replication factors so
far so on because underlying stuff so
things when would you create create
stream we actually create Kafka topic
we're actually creating some sort of
storage on the Kafka side so they they
not ephemeral all right so now we talked
a little bit about the things that
allows us to modify the current message
so we do some transformation we do some
filtering now it's called stateless
stream processing you don't need to know
the previous result in order to
calculate current result if you need to
calculate some of the results that
requires some information from the past
you do counting it yura Gatien you do
some sort of grouping you do some sort
of joints this is what we call stateful
stream processing in this case the state
intermediate through the intermediate
State needs to be handled somewhere so
key cycle has built-in mechanism to to
provide this facility for you so they'll
need to think about this yourself
underlying mechanisms also will be Kafka
some some of the state stores that key
cycle will have in memory on the
processor side of key sequel will be
replicated through Kafka as well so
here's example how we can do like
enrichment the type of procedure so we
do have some information about orders
that already somehow appeared in Kafka
topic so maybe we have this information
now we're Enterprise database and this
information was replicated to Kafka so
we can materialize as a table inside
inside the key sequel KC cooperates with
two things tables and streams streams is
the sequence of events table represents
a state think about this if you play in
the chance how menu playing chess here
if you play in the chest in your party
don't trust your partners you what you
do what you do you record all moves when
you're recording all moves you're
generating stream of events that
represents particular move if you
looking at this particular the chess
board and how the figure is the position
of this board you know the state so if
you will replay this particular stream
of events you always will get the
current state on individual time so this
is how we transform stream of events
into table table represent state stream
represents history so here we go same
table versus streams in 20 seconds now
we have a table that represents order
which is going to be our lookup we need
to in reach our incoming stream of
events and we perform in so called
stream to table join so we performing
this similar way how we can do with
traditional traditional database joints
and we we interested in this particular
case we interested in enriching this
order that has an item ID where we can
look up by item ID in the table that
will have all this data and after that
we will produce a result that will
include in the rich stream enriched
based on this table data so this is how
it result looks like so in this
particular case we see some elements
that came from our lookup table in some
elements of cam and real-time and stream
so how we can integrate with the
external system so by the time when the
graph becomes very popular people start
thinking how we can do this people start
writing small apps every time when they
do I don't know like they do like Oracle
communication the do MongoDB and the
start writing small apps instead of
writing these small apps
Cuffy community come up with the
framework called Kafka Connect that
allows people to develop connectors so
you can build your pipelines without
bringing much of the coding so in this
case there's a Kafka connect connector
for elasticsearch that allows you to do
some stuff with case equal and after
that this connector will automatically
dump this into elastic you'll have a
very nice visualization they're using
Cubana in some some other stuff
you can perform certain aggregation
would you include certain aggregating
functions that allows you to do things
like count so would you include this the
function out of the box there is a
multiple functions that available you
can write your own aggregating functions
as well so this is how the result for
particular key would look like couple
interesting use cases so sometimes we
want to transform the stream so we want
to not put from join but their firm
rather merge or like how you can do like
it zip join or sub type of thing so here
are two streams that Kem's different
orders that come in from say the New
York and like US and UK and we want you
have a for some reasons we want to have
a stream that has all orders we don't
need to do joins they will be just
joined the way how they will arrive so
in this case there's nothing to do with
water and and how they will appear
alright you can do similar similar
operation if you do kind of splitting
we've seen this already in the past and
I think that we're ready for some some
demo right right you prepare your
Twitter's alright so what's gonna be at
what it's gonna be
so in this is here here I'm running my
case equal this is my cluster that has
multiple Kafka's multiple zookeepers how
we can tell if some of the projects
actually related to Big Data somehow it
has a zookeeper as a dependency some
people actually there's another version
people saying it has a patch in his name
yeah probably but like if if you're
dealing with some big data project
problem zookeeper someone there
interesting thing here I'm using this
thing called a Twitter connector that
simply sits there and listening all the
events that happened on the Twitter
firehose for particular keyboard you
know this keyword right data the Ad
Council alright so we're using this
hashtag to do some of the some some
stuff so Kafka allows me not only to
loosen some of the real-time events so
for example if I'll do select
wait would connection feel okay let me
see if I need to reconnect to my this is
what I'm saying
yeah the demos always always break
let me reconnect King alright so you see
if the Wi-Fi is working we have here
let's see so now you can tweet with data
console and we'll be using my the
Twitter handle if you want to your
Twitter peer I'm not gonna wait because
I'm gonna be do what all Russian people
are known of doing creating a bunch of
fake Twitter accounts and I will go here
just switching to my friends kafka
accounts and let me see and eat dinner
console okay this guy is
let's do important thing yay let's see
if I kiss equal supports emojis no I saw
that they twit goes okay so I think
we'll have a good round of applause that
at least our premise works for demo we
still have five minutes to do some cool
stuff so what I usually do in this kind
of setting
I also can do is to set I can reset this
offset so I'm meaning that my
application like a sequel query can
actually query the data that already in
Kafka topic so in this case I reset my
set if I run this select it actually
will bring all the queries from I guess
from yesterday when I was testing this
thing and also will display this on the
screen and will continue to reading this
data as it goes here so it says press
control C to interrupt so meaning that I
will be running here is continuous query
so in this case when I will done with
this I will just kill it
I'll just control C so done my query is
done so in order me to create
in query so I can you know just like
close laptop and continue do my stuff
and my key seeker will do things for me
so let me switch back here okay so what
I will do here okay this is my - it will
already seen this number five okay I can
perform certain certain aggregated
aggregated calculations so in this
particular case I will be interested in
getting a tweet counts this is user
tweet count for for specific time frame
so key cycle has this capability that
allows you to perform Fenian operations
on infinite stream of data so in this
particular case the I don't know when
the oldest tweets will stop coming right
I'm assuming that you're still tweeting
and they keep coming but I'm interesting
or tweets for the last hour because this
was where my presentation was and I'm
interesting how the people are reacted
this one so I created this one within
our that allows me to have this state so
as you can see here I'm creating a table
because I'm trying to do aggregation
result and I don't care about history so
I'm just interesting in in counts so
what I can do I can also create some
pretty print versions so in this case I
will extract my raw time what that will
be defined in my when the window started
I will be able to see say let's do - not
the tree right so not everyone wants to
tweet maybe but and I will do something
like here and right now
I need to tweet more or my alter ego
needs to tweet more so - - - and okay
is is a sequel is awesome
let's do one because
Twitter will not allow me to place
delicates and so in this case you have
two two and three and I should be able
to see who's tweeting about who's
tweeting and who's in fire here okay so
as you can see here so what happened my
tweet went to Internet Twitter give me
this result and now I'm constantly
creating this aggregated state with
couple lines of sequel court or sequel
line code alright so operation and
deployment case sequel is a Java process
but you can deploy this in any package
that you would like has a packages for
for Linux it has Dockers my particular
demo runs in kubernetes and just just
continuously running there I I can I can
scale my case equal as I need to because
and I can scale this independently from
my craft because it depends on the
certain use cases that I'm using we also
have a key sequel in the cloud if you
interested in full-blown let me just
bring more and more the buzzwords like
full-blown server less cloud native
stream processing functionality so
basically you can run key sequence
you can run cough can cloud you can run
connectors in cloud so you don't need to
run this stuff for yourself you can run
this just to submit your key sequel
query and you'll be good to go
you can operate with the UI you can
operate this with the CLI you can
operate this using the rest interface
they key sequel can be deployed on a
different host it's supposed to be
deployed on different host and Kafka
because we usually not recommend
anyone's runs near to Kafka and still
they talk to each other through the
network and there's an intrinsic mode
that allows you to deploy this in
production that called headless mode
that allows you to write your stream
processing application and sequel file
ship this sequel file into Ndoki sigil
and lock down this environment so you're
writing your app in sequel key sequel is
not like your database you're not
running a sequel for
everything even though you can sew usual
use case is that that there's no like a
one-size-fits-all you can use these
different sizes for different use cases
if you do like a simple simple type of
like a filtering or simple like the
normalization of the data you can run
this with like one instance here right
so we have one instance of kis equal
we're running more sophisticated the use
case for example some fraud detection
we're running this with the two
instances and we're running some sort of
like a very heavy aggregation type of
thing we will be running this in more
nodes control center provides monitoring
capabilities we expose all the metrics
from key signals of gmx so essentially
any tool that understand gmx will be
able to use it now that brings us to the
great idea that the founders of the
craft had in mind when they developed
this in in LinkedIn that all streams
leads to Kafka eventually platform and
the key sequel is a kind of first
horseman of this of this era
now what about databases how about this
stuff that we actually you know getting
data from legacy system existing system
and things like that so we do have all
these connectors already available if
you do the confluent io / hop you can
find at the App Store for connectors
that we call it
it's a confluent hub you can find any
connector now what we actually do in
we're actually creating this boundary
that Allah requires you as a data
engineer to you know bring this
connector frameworks in there you need
to understand how to configure this now
you can do this within kisi ko ki sequel
will be able to create the connectors so
the data will be constantly pumping from
your database or be constantly out you
know constantly reading from some sort
of this source so that allows you to
create this this connector also it's a
clip K sequel improvement proposal
number seven and a key sequel
improvement proposal number eight is
actually allows to query key sigil the
way how you can query your traditional
database in order to get what we call
the pool queries so you will get a state
and you can use kiss eagle as your
database you don't need to actually dump
data anywhere so you can follow the
process of development of kiss eagle
here thank you so much for being with me
we have a slack community if you not
enough with 10 or 15 slacks that you
already have probably please join our
slack as well we do have a group where
the people talking about key sequel
people talking about Kafka stream
processing kubernetes I'm hanging out in
the kubernetes channel sometimes so
thank you for for your time if you don't
have a Twitter and you didn't create a
Twitter during this presentation you can
send me email email how many you have
emails send me mail so basically thank
you so much for your time and I will be
available for enhanced interrogation in
the separate room as well as his way I
was told thank you so much make sure the
first question that I suppose the most
important for developers it's okay about
filtering incoming events
yeah and joints is quite tricky what
about performance isn't it easy
in case of performance collect all data
on the database side and perform joints
why temporary tables are all that this
is how you can find the Russian person
in the room because the first question
would be about performance this is this
is this is perfect question so in order
to answer this question there's couple
things so we're not joining all this
massive amount of data and one shot it's
not like your traditional join that you
do when you need to have a data already
available in the both sides it's
actually what you joining is is it just
a few messages that comes into into your
stream so you might have some sort of a
data that already aggregated which means
that you already store this somewhere so
it's not about joining in this case it's
about more storage and how much memory
it will use the the performance wise it
still relies on these like high
performance libraries like kafka streams
and the consumer and producer API so all
this the good thing about Kafka you can
tweak everything but
about Kafka you need to tweak things and
in order to answer about performance
because it's really way question so I
need to know the answers for some
questions like what's your size of the
messages what's the what's the ratio how
man just arrived case equal does support
at the metrics it will expose like when
you do this kind of join you will do if
you'll have a time I can show you this
in in our office hours I can show you
that you can see they how many messages
go through this particular query what's
the performance of this query this
information is available in order to you
to observe this introspect and make some
sort of decision so in general works
very well we do have a lot of customers
who are using this already in production
workloads and they using it a serious
amount of data to you know pumping
through key sequel and again you can
scale things up if you will see there's
some sort of like limitation in terms
how the data will you know go through it
doesn't do any remote joining data will
be collocated based on partition scheme
but in this case that we need to a
little bit more time to talk about how
the the scalability think works inside
the Kafka but in general the performance
very well numbers are there you can
always measure yourself if you can't
measure it can control it so
[Music]